let's talk about the seven warning signs
that your kidneys are
toxic now i want to do a comprehensive
video on the kidney but in a very very
simple way without teaching you all the
fluff and the extra things that you
don't need to know so we're just going
to focus on the most important things
you need to know
to prevent a toxic kidney as well as
what to do if you have toxic kidneys now
what is the purpose of the kidneys
well it mainly filters the blood but not
like an oil filter in your car it's much
more complex
it gets rid of the toxic things and it
will help to reabsorb all the good
things so the more you lose this complex
filtering function you start getting rid
of nutrients that you need and you hold
waste products they start backing up
into the system and so all of the
symptoms both in the early stage kidney
problems as well as the late stage
kidney problems are directly related to
this filtering system becoming damaged
now some of the top early symptoms would
be a metallic taste in your mouth that
means your toxins are backing up into
the system you have itchiness in your
body and you can also have ammonia
breath now some of the later signs that
your kidneys are toxic would be edema
okay swelling where you put your finger
into your lower leg and it leaves a dent
and so you're going to notice swelling
in the lower ankles and feet now this
also shows up with the kidney because
the liver and the kidney work together
but if you have pitting edema in your
lower extremities
your kidneys are toxic now the other
place you're going to see edema is
underneath the eyes okay you're going to
see these kind of puffy swollen bags
underneath your eyes
that is the kidneys backing up another
symptom that you may get is called
uremic frost now what is uremic frost
things are backing up in the system
especially uric acid
and it's backing up through the skin
usually on the scalp or the front part
of your head you'll see these little
white specks like frost
on your skin that is urea backing up in
the system because the body's not able
to get rid of it and it's coming through
your skin
another common sign would be high blood
pressure because think about it if the
filter is damaged it's going to kind of
inhibit blood flow to the kidney and
it's going to back up its back pressure
and one of the problems with high blood
pressure is that pressure itself will
damage the kidneys because if you think
about having too much pressure through
this pipe
and hitting this filter it'd be very
similar to having a water filter in your
house and you you put way too much
pressure in these pipes it's going to
damage the filtering mechanism so the
kidney being a filter
is really made up of these tiny little
filters
called
glomeruli
and each kidney has about a million of
them and they do the work of filtering
and kind of recycling
certain nutrients so you're not wasting
all the vitamins and minerals and amino
acids all right another really common
sign that your kidneys are toxic is that
you are exhausted okay you're tired now
the mechanism of what makes you tired is
urea which is kind of a waste product of
protein too much of that in the blood
and you're just going to be so tired
number five
protein in the urine if you get a urine
test and there's
large amounts of protein that you're in
suspect that your kidneys are toxic and
they're damaged now if there's a small
amount of protein that could mean
something else but if you have a lot of
protein coming through this filter
there's holes in the filter okay they're
damaged all right number six is very
acidic urine your body becomes more acid
and this comes from
a imbalance with ammonia because ammonia
is very very alkaline and so it's not
able to buffer things that well and so
you have ammonia building up in certain
places in the body and not in others and
it throws off your ph now the other
reason why you can become acidic is
especially if you're a diabetic is that
you're running out of insulin so you
have these uncontrolled
blood sugars
and if you don't watch it you can
develop something called
ketoacidosis but i just want to mention
that's completely different than
nutritional ketosis where you're
changing your diet you're getting into
ketosis ketoacidosis
occurs when you are a diabetic and
you're not taking your medication and
you're not regulating your blood sugars
well all right number seven
low vitamin d now if you watch some of
my other videos in the vitamin d
the kidney is very very important so is
the liver but the kidney helps
in the first conversion
from the inactive vitamin d to the
active vitamin d so without good kidney
function you're not going to be able to
change vitamin d into its active form
and so you're going to have a vitamin d
deficiency despite how much vitamin d
you take
as well as a calcium deficiency and that
can lead to all sorts of other problems
like calcification your arteries
atherosclerosis
kidney stones calcium and building up in
the arteries calcium building up in your
eyes calcium building up in the nerves
as neuritis and the list goes on and on
and on now i want to actually shift
gears to the main causes
of
kidney damage hands down the number one
cause is diabetes specifically when you
have
high levels of glucose flowing through
the body and through the kidney glucose
to the kidney is like taking steel wool
or sandpaper and just rubbing the inside
of your kidney it just destroys the
kidney the kidney is one of four main
body tissues
that gets destroyed with high glucose
the other tissues is the heart like the
blood vessels then you have the nerves
in the brain and then the eyes so
diabetes just hammers the kidney and
destroys the kidney now i just want to
bring up one little side note which i'm
going to do another video on
if you take a look at normal blood
sugars right normal blood sugar would be
like 80
milligrams per deciliter
okay what does this 80 mean
how much sugar is in the blood when it
says 80. it's only four grams that's
like one teaspoon of sugar
okay to make up normal blood sugar
an average person
per day consumes
well over usually it's 15 or more
teaspoons every single day and they have
that going through their blood system
right but a lot of times well initially
it doesn't show up in your blood test it
doesn't show up as abnormal blood sugar
and this is because your body works
really hard
at
keeping sugar out of the blood and it
does that through a hormone called
insulin so it's constantly just taking
the sugar out and so it's trying to keep
your arteries free of this excess sugar
because of the damage it creates but
think about this where is all the sugar
going your body is putting it in other
places and this is one of the signs of
diabetes is where you have sugar in the
urine and so the kidney filter has to
work really hard at getting rid of
excess sugar and this excess sugar is
like a blow torch to your kidney it just
it creates oxidation and it creates a
lot of damage i'm just amazed that the
body actually responds and survives as
well as it does with the amount of sugar
that an average person consumes all
right so the primary cause of kidney
problems is diabetes and the second
cause is high blood pressure which a lot
of times is caused by diabetes
because glucose hardens the arteries
increasing the pressure because there's
no elasticity the other two
really big causes of high blood pressure
is low vitamin d which could be caused
by a kidney problem
and low potassium which can then cause
kidney damage and high blood pressure
can also affect diabetes as well so it's
kind of this circuit that just one
causes another problem and causes
another problem back and forth now
another cause not very common but it can
cause
kidney damage is polycystic kidney
disease now this is usually a genetic
problem
that
manifests when you get
kidney damage and so the genes are
usually expressed or get triggered when
your body becomes toxic especially the
kidney in later stage kidney disease
people a lot of times will develop these
cysts all right then another cause of
kidney damage would be
glomerulonephritis which is inflammation
of those little
filters those glomeruli so the question
is what causes inflammation of these
little filtering units well if you guess
diabetes you are correct so you pretty
much conclude that the majority of
kidney problems come from
high blood glucose okay so what can you
do with that information
well
let's see
go on the low carb diet that might help
all right before i get to the foods i
want to just mention potassium for a
second
if you have end stage
kidney disease
you're not supposed to be consuming too
much potassium okay
you're not supposed to be consuming too
much phosphorus because both of those
minerals are in high levels and of
course if you have end stage kidney
disease you know your doctor is going to
advise you on what to take what not to
take
but i want to tell you something
if you don't have end stage kidney
disease okay
and you want to prevent end stage kidney
disease potassium is one of the most
important minerals to consume enough of
because potassium can protect the kidney
and i'm going to put some links down
below for those of you that want
hardcore data and i'm talking about not
just a supplement i'm talking about
consuming high potassium foods now the
other two things i want to mention is
vitamin d when you have kidney damage
you're nearly always going to be
low in vitamin d and then because
vitamin d is low you're also going to be
low in calcium the problem is now we
don't have this transportation mechanism
of calcium and you start building up
calcification in your arteries and in
your joints
and then your kidney as kidney stones
all right now that you have that let's
talk about the best
foods for the kidney in preventing
kidney damage hands down the best foods
are
leafy greens okay asparagus is awesome
for the kidney because it also helps
detoxify uric acid we also have kale
which is loaded with all sorts of
phytonutrients that are kidney
protective and then celery celery has
great nutrients to help detoxify the
kidneys and keep the kidneys in good
health
and do it in a very very gentle way
celery juice
taken periodically is a great way to
kind of filter out the kidney and you're
going to see if someone has puffy eyes
they tend to clear up very fast when
someone consumes a good amount of celery
i think if someone had weakness in the
kidney
and they consumed celery every single
day maybe right at the meal last meal or
maybe a little bit later
it would not just help the kidney it
would also help them sleep but celery is
really good for edema
both in the ankles and underneath the
eyes now as far as protein fish and
seafood is the best as well as high
quality meats i'm talking about organic
talking about grass fed but you don't
want to do necessarily high protein you
want to do a moderate amount of protein
you don't want to do a low protein
a moderate amount that would be between
three and six ounces maybe seven ounces
per meal now it's very very important to
step up the quality of food
when you want to prevent kidney problems
because
yes diabetes high blood glucose destroys
the kidney but also
drugs destroy the kidney and medications
destroy the kidney
many different medications have a side
effect to the kidney itself because the
kidney is always filtering blood and
that's where your medications and drugs
end up so if you're constantly exposing
the kidney to medications and drugs
it's going to damage those kidneys we
don't want to consume food with
pesticides and herbicides
we don't want to have coffee that's not
organic because of the amount of
pesticides that they spray and the other
point i want to bring up is many people
that
have kidney problems
are on a low sodium diet and so
they're obviously probably not even
consuming any salt okay which then makes
your muscles weak okay you're going to
feel very weak and you'll feel very very
lethargic there is a very
awesome salt that is naturally very low
in sodium
so sea salt which has like 90 minerals
normally has over 95 percent of it
sodium but there's a type of sea salt
called baja gold sea salt that is 70
percent
sodium and it has 90 minerals
it's very high in potassium and very
high in magnesium so it's very very good
not just for the kidney but good for the
entire body and it's quite delicious on
your food in fact it'll really bring out
the flavors of your food and i will put
a link down below i'm not associated
with this company at all but it's a very
very good salt to get your potassium
magnesium without just going really
heavy on the sodium now obviously
refined foods junk foods
high sugary foods high carb foods
are all damaging to the kidney but there
are so called healthy foods that are
also damaging to the kidney because they
have high amounts of oxalates okay
oxalates form with calcium to form
oxalate stones that can damage the
kidney so the foods that you probably
should avoid
if you do have kidney problems would be
spinach
almonds
kiwi
beet leaves
and of course things like beans and
grains
things like that the other point i want
to bring up with how much liquid you
should drink and if you have damage in
your kidney you should drink at least
2.5 liters per day that will keep your
kidneys from concentrating and
developing these little stones
all right last point and this is very
very important
if you have
damage in your kidney
there is a very very good supplement
that i would recommend
and i don't sell it you can do a search
on the internet and find it
it's from a product called standard
process and it's called rena food just
take one of these before bed
for about two to three months
i used to recommend it in practice with
really good results with kidney damage
all right now that you have this
information the next most important
thing you need to know is
what's the complete diet look like what
should i be eating okay
you need to be on the healthy keto plan
and i have several short step-by-step
videos right here check them out
you